>> You ready for a quiz?
>> Yes, I am.
>> Okay. Here's what I'd like you to do. I'd like
you to use these probabilities that we have written down here,
that, that constitute the joint distribution of, when you look out
do you see a storm, do you see lightning? And use these
numbers to answer some other questions that aren't directly in here
but you can figure it out. So, the first one is to
say, what's the probability when you look out the window at
2 PM in the summer, in Atlanta, that there's no storm, okay?
>> Okay. And, then the question is to say,
what's the probability that if there is
a storm, there is also lightning, okay? So
the probability of lightning given that there
is a storm. And we've done some stuff
with conditional probability. So these concepts should
be familiar with you, but you should be
able to connect it up with, you know, the numbers in the table. You ready?
>> I am ready.
>> Go.